how was he on set was he friendly
that son of a [ __ ] always late
salty yeah incredibly difficult
halitosis
he was pretty good to work with but
unfortunately you know we kept sending
him the catering and repeating
so we went through many many many
caterers on this film nom nom
kinder spirits you know because uh king
shot and i would
fight over the protein and grab her like
he bit one of the caterers not cool so
define
he ate one of the caters gustavo was a
good man but he missed
he made a mean poutine there's a lot of
assistant cameramen
they're close to set you know i think
king start kind of got you know don't
mess with the camera operator he's a
person of of substance but the assistant
camera person he thought was disposable
and so he would eat a lot of that
he's always
[Applause]
he's the circling of guy you know hell
is big whatever so i was like playing
with your emotions you know like he's
always kind of like
he gives you that hot and cold you know
i can't say anything bad about him
because he's twice as
strong as the strongest thing that i
know and he'll just consume you as a
human being
don't trust anything with fins and hands
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die
you